if I asked you what you thought most
people associate with ancient Greece you
would probably mention something about
philosophy and rationalism the great
thinkers of the ancient world such as
Socrates Plato Aristotle and these
stoics are of course household names
that have come to represent the ancient
Greek Legacy but this picture is usually
incomplete ancient Greece and these
thinkers to many represent some kind of
pure rationalistic or scientific ever a
precursor to our own enlightened age
before it was interrupted by the
entrance of religion and Superstition
which dominated human thinking until the
Renaissance or even the
enlightenment this image of history is
of course criminally Incorrect and
oversimplified and for various different
reasons not least because the ancient
Greeks aren't really what many people
assume at least not if we base our
understanding on the above narrative
that I mentioned in fact while figures
like Plato indeed put an emphasis on
reason an argument to come to many of
their philosophical conclusions this is
not the whole picture many of these same
philosophers were also deeply involved
in things that we would call religious
practice or even mysticism and even saw
that as a superior way to reach truth
than through limited reason and human
intellect in fact ancient Greece was
filled with different kinds of what we
could call Mystical practices and
mystical experiences which have been
largely ignored at least earlier in
history
have been largely ignored by many
historians working on this topic it
doesn't really fit into our Narrative of
the ancient Greeks as our sort of uh
rational intellectual ancestors and the
way that we portray this topic really
says more about ourselves in the way
that we see ourselves than it does about
the actual people we're trying to
portray so in this episode we're going
to once again look at this more
forgotten aspect of ancient Greek
culture as we explore very broadly what
we could call mysticism or mystical
experiences in the ancient helenic
[Music]
world where does one begin to cover such
a broad topic we will of course have to
limit ourselves to certain expressions
of what we call quote unquote mysticism
here what even is mysticism returning
viewers will know that it is a contested
term and concept and it's of course even
more so when we use it outside of a
Christian or at least abrahamic
framework in this case we have a bit
more luck in the sense that the term
mysticism or at least Mystic and
mystical actually are Greek words
originally coming from the term M
meaning conceal or mysos meaning in
initiate with that said the word doesn't
really get the meaning that we associate
with it today until the writings of the
Christian Theologian pseudo dianus and
even more so really during the 16th and
17th centuries when the term mysticism
became a thing but keeping in mind what
we have said in earlier episodes about
it we can here also use a kind of
working definition of mysticism or
mystical as that which concerns
experiences of practices related to and
explanations of direct encounters with
with the Divine usually also accompanied
by Altered States Of Consciousness with
this definition we can find it all over
ancient gree while the incorrect picture
of ancient Greece that I mentioned above
is still very prevalent even among
academics and historians many have begun
to question it and present an
alternative history of this culture
among them is of course the scholar ER
dods who especially with this
foundational work the Greeks and the
irrational show that we need to take
these other what he calls irrational
aspects of ancient Greece into serious
consideration and this of course
includes famous aspects like the
prophetic role of the oracles such as
the most famous one at Deli who received
messages from the gods through ecstatic
Altered States Of
Consciousness we also have the influence
of the amuses on poets and artists what
Plato refers to as poetic Mania a poet
can never create by his own imagination
something as great and beautiful as a
work influenced by the Divine Madness
imparted by the muses
but we should perhaps begin this
discussion by exploring one of the most
fascinating aspects of ancient helenic
culture religion and quote unquote
mysticism the mystery Cults this is a
category that denotes several different
movements that were initiatory in
different ways and which promis to their
initiates some kind of secret knowledge
or wisdom some of the more prominent of
these are the ucini Mysteries the bakic
Cults of dianis and the so-called orix
many would even argue that early py
paganism was also a kind of mystery cult
and the Elian Mysteries was the largest
and most popular or famous of these
mystery Cults indeed in ancient times it
is thought that the majority of
Athenians so citizens of the city of
Athens were initiated into the alinan
Mysteries this was an annual initiatory
event that took place in the town of
elus close to
Athens on the days of the ritual
hundreds or maybe even thousands of
people would walk from Athens to elus
swinging branches and singing songs once
on location they would also fast and
then drink a beverage called the Kon
before entering a building called the
telesterion where the core of the secret
ritual took place we actually don't know
a lot of details about what went on in
the telesterion um this was a secret
ritual and people weren't really
supposed to talk about what what went on
at this ritual and most people seem to
have kept their mouth shut uh what we do
know is that the ritual revolved around
certain mythical stories particularly
around two goddesses demer and panie
also known as Corey and particularly the
story when pany is abducted by Hades to
the underworld and then demer her mother
is is sort of distraught trying to find
her she seeks the help of the Gods who
help her eventually spoiler alert
retrieve pania back from the underworld
and so this is a sort of um it's imagery
that talks about the changing of the
seasons and stuff like this but so this
is the the mythical account that is at
the center of the elosan Mysteries and
this descent into the underworld of
prephan is a very key theme a very key
feature of this myth that is sort of
symbolically um played out in certain
ways during this ritual it seems that
the initiat were taken through an
intense experience involving Altered
States Of Consciousness where they would
somehow simulate epan descent into the
underworld dying to then be reborn once
again at the end of the ritual this
stuff seems to have been very intense
and the initiates are said to have been
completely transformed by The Experience
many even claiming to lose their fear of
death entirely after going through this
initiation the initiate would be led by
the priests through rituals that induced
Altered States Of Consciousness which
could reveal truths about the Divine
myths or about reality itself these
Altered States which are referred to in
Greek with terms like Mania and Baka
meant an ecstatic transformation of the
person that had lasting effects on the
rest of his or her life and meant that
they were now initiated into the
Mysteries parts of the ritual seems to
have been quite scary and traumatic as
basically they would simulate your death
The Scholar Julia OVA writes quote
mystery writes were intended to unsettle
disturb and horrify as only in absolute
contrast to the initial Terror could the
initiate arrive at a Prof profound
modification of his attitude to life
after going through the painful
experience of death although not a real
death of course the initiate would then
ideally enter a state of ecstasy a
feeling of immortality and even of
uniting with the
Divine this peak was often accompanied
by a vision of pure light and a feeling
of
transcendence the proceedings in the
telesterion also seem to have involve
things like music and ecstatic dancing
to induce these Altered States and as we
said this wasn't some Fringe sact on the
sidelines of society but a prominent
aspect of life in ancient Greece and
especially in around Athens and many of
the philosophers that we know and love
so associated with sober rationalism
were themselves initiated into the ucan
mysteries for example one of my favorite
descriptions of the powerful experiences
had during the ritual comes from the
platonic philosopher plutar quote at
first there was wandering and where is
some roaming and some fearful Journeys
through unending darkness and just
before the end every sort of Terror
shuddering and trembling in sweat and
amazement out of these emerges Marvelous
Light and pure places and Meadows follow
after with voices and dances and
solemnities of sacred utterances and
holy Visions among these the completely
initiated mes walk freely and without
restraint crowned he takes part in
rights and joins with pure and Pious
people he observes the crowd of people
living at this very time uninitiated and
unpurified who are driven together and
trample each other in deep mud and
darkness and continue in their fear of
death their evils and their disbelief in
the good things in the other world then
in accordance with nature the soul stays
engaged with the body in close Union
thereafter that is some powerful stuff
and shows just how intense this
initiation ritual and its effects must
have been the linian Mysteries was an
annual event and once you went through
the ritual once you were now an initiate
a mysts in Greek meaning initiate which
is of course where the term Mystic comes
from but like we said the mystery calls
are very varied some say that even
having this as a general category is is
kind of there are issues with this
because the different mystery cults look
very different from each other so the
Elan Mysteries was a an event right it
was it was an event that people went
through once a year or it happened once
a year and people would go through it
once of course you could do it multiple
times but the purpose was to become
initiated through this one event whereas
other famous mystery Cults were more
similar to what we would associate with
the word cult right a sort of group an
initiatory group with certain rituals
and practices and beliefs in this
context we should of course mention
Pythagoras and the pythagoreans as
another example of this kind of movement
now I'm not going to do a thorough dive
into that topic since I have dedicated
two previous episodes to pythagoreanism
in the past but contrary to popular
belief Pythagoras himself if he even
existed historically was not necessarily
associated with mathematics but was
rather a kind of wonderwork sage who
started an initiatory movement concerned
with ritual rules and practices
including a strict vegetarianism a
hatred towards beans and many other
practices it isn't as easy to find
rituals of Altered States Of
Consciousness with the pythagoreans but
they share many features with the other
mystery Cults such as a concern with the
soul and the afterlife and might have
involved similar practices to what we
can see in the other groups the
pythagoreans is an important part of the
puzzle when understanding the ancient
helenic world and makes apparent to us
some of the common misconceptions we
have about the period so Pythagoras is a
very good example of this we see
Pythagoras as the sort of originator of
maths almost like he came up with the
Pythagorean theorem that we all learn in
school he was a sort of rational
philosoph phos opher um and while he
might have been associated with
mathematics you know some of the earlier
pythagoreans like a century later do
concern themselves with mathematics as a
way of understanding the universe
looking at the universe as math in some
way uh like Phil La for instance we
mentioned in the earlier episode but
there is no evidence that Pythagoras
himself was involved with that at all
right that might have been part of the
initiatory teachings in this group that
he started which we don't know of
because they were secret esoteric
teachings of course uh but in general
the image that we get of Pythagoras from
the earlier sources is of a sort of sage
a figure who sort of can travel with his
soul to different places he does
miraculous things almost like a demigod
uh and he starts this this sort of group
this initiatory almost like a m many
would refer to it as a kind of mystery
cult similar to what is sometimes
referred to as the orix which we will
return to uh and that he
and his group The pythagoreans were
primarily concerned with ritual rules of
conduct certain ways of living you were
not allowed to do this you were not not
allowed to do that that was what the
pythagoreans was and what Pythagoras was
whereas our common image of Pythagoras
is of this rational
mathematician which these early sources
do not really support moving on another
one of the most prominent Mysteries was
the aforementioned bakic Cult of dionis
dionis was a god associated with wine
Mak
fertility and indeed Mania or Madness
and religious ecstasy he was also known
as bakus precisely because he was
thought to be able to induce a state of
Madness in people called
Baka and the Mystery Cult of dianis
often called The bakic Cult was
associated with precisely this its
practitioners going into intense Altered
States Of Consciousness and ecstasy
often accompanied by being united with
God or being possessed by him often when
we talk talk about the Bic Mysteries we
divide it into the spontaneous frenzied
nonorganized cult mostly associated with
women on the one hand and a more
initiatory organized group in the city
environment although both share similar
key features in terms of the first
category there was a tradition where
women known as mids would work
themselves into an ecstatic state by
different means this cult was almost
exclusively associated with women who
would leave their homes and go together
Into the Wilderness where they would
perform rituals involving music and
dancing as well as possible intoxicants
with the aim of inducing a state of
Madness and ecstasy what is again
referred to as Baka after which they
would start behaving like animals
wearing animal skins and roam around the
countryside there are even some very
dramatic stories of how these manets
while in this frenzied state would kill
other human beings how true these more
dramatic stories are is hard to say but
the general characteristics of the cult
was probably very much true there are
several ceramic vases and other works of
art that depict such maned women in a
state of ecstasy so what was all this
about well as we've seen inducing states
of ecstasy in Altered States Of
Consciousness is a commonly recurring
theme in many different religious
Traditions here just like in so many
other examples when the person enters
the state of baka they disappear from
themselves the regular person or self
that they associate with in their
regular life completely vanishes being
taken over by something else in this
case the God dianis and His ecstatic
Madness as we saw this feeling of dying
to oneself is a state sought by many
Mystics throughout history as a feeling
of release and ecstasy and of being
united with higher realities and we seem
to find the same thing here at least
something very close to it furthermore
there are probably psychological and
soci iological factors at play too women
in ancient Greece and especially in
cities like Athens were very limited in
their movement and power being
essentially confined to the home and
under the control of men being able to
go out into the Wilderness Escape from
regular life and completely lose
themselves in frantic unhinged Behavior
was probably a kind of psychological
release from the constraints of regular
life the mads are a really fascinating
group that according to some definitions
could certainly be considered a kind of
mysticism and as we said there seems to
have been a more organized initiatory
aspect of the Dian cult as well
primarily in these cities this cult was
popular among both men and women and
seems to have been pretty mainstream but
in a very similar way it used Altered
States Of Consciousness and ecstasy
induced by music and dancing as the
ritual means for
initiation through this bokic ecstasy
one becomes United with the Divine and
it's imparted with mystical iCal
knowledge leading to both a more
enlightened life in this world but also
a more pleasant afterlife that very much
recurring theme in all of the mystery
Cults the dionan cult is also often
associated with another possible mystery
cult the so-called
orix now orphism or the orix is a very
complicated topic Scholars have been
disagreeing on this for centuries not
being able to conclude if orphism as a
distinct group actually existed or if it
is a historical Mirage so to say the
term usually refers to practices and
beliefs held by people who Associated
these practices with the ancient
mythical figure orus a poet and musician
to whom is described many famous myths
as well as hymns and writings that serve
as the basis for much esoteric and
mystical interpretation Orpheus is also
famous for having travel to the
underworld what is known as katabasis a
motif that we find in many mystery Cults
and myths about the gods which often
come to represent and be represented by
certain rituals and mystical insights we
saw this with the ucan Mysteries we saw
this in the dionan um myths and we see
it here with orus as well orus is
strongly associated with teeli Mysteries
generally as the originator of mystery
rituals and practices and many do
believe that this made up a distinct
mystery cult similar to and connected
with the pythagoreans and bics for
instance
and we indeed see many similarities
between the practices of these Mysteries
and those ascribed to the so-called
orics including vegetarianism and
particular ritual rules such as the
prohibition of burying the Dead with
wool the ancient historian Herodotus
connects the orphics bakic and
pythagoreans by stating that they all
somehow originate with the Egyptians
while we should be careful to accept
such claims too easily since this kind
of orientalism was was very common of a
Trope in ancient times which didn't
always represent reality but at the same
time there are other aspects that might
point in that direction for example the
occupation of many of the mystery Cults
with the afterlife including orphic
writings giving instructions on how to
travel in the afterlife this of course
reminds us of very similar traditions in
Egypt such as the famous book of the
dead or book of going forth by day but
orphism as such as we said is a pretty
complicated topic because it's not clear
at all if there was such a thing as a
coherent group or tradition known as
orphism it might have been more so the
case that orus as a figure was so
strongly associated with teet with
Mysteries and mystery rights right that
many of these actual mystery Cults such
as the Bak cult or the pythagoreans
perhaps um would sort of
ascribe their rituals to to orus as a
kind of authority as as a way of
legitimizing your tradition by saying
these rights originate with orus right
so he becomes a kind of a omnipotent um
symbol for all these ancient um mystery
Cults in that way uh that could have
been the case and in that sense there
wouldn't be a group that were known as
the or the orix or a tradition as known
as orphism but that this was a general
sort of more abstract um idea that that
existed Within These more concrete uh
mystery groups or mystery initiations
but let's pretend that there was such a
thing as the quote unquote orphic
mystery cult in ancient times their
rituals May then have symbolically
involved this descent into the
underworld what is known as katabasis it
was common in ancient Greece for seeking
wisdom to in a ritual way enter into
dark caves for extended periods one
would go down into a certain cave might
be met by a priest or ritual expert and
maybe consumed some sort of intoxicant
or substance whatever the case people
would have intense experiences of
Altered States Of Consciousness in these
caves which would lead them to higher
wisdom and
knowledge perhaps this serve as one such
example of a ritual or practice
associated with katabasis or descent
which is again particularly also
associated with orphism as the
initiatory descent into the cave of
mysteries symbolically represents the
descent into the underworld and the
knowledge gained from this experience in
any case these phenomena tell us a few
important things it is significant that
all three of the mystery calls we have
described so far all involved katabasis
the again the descent into the
underworld as a motif orus is said to
have done so dianis is associated with
such a journey and even pany in the
famous mythical account is abducted by
Hades into the underworld before being
retrieved by her mother which also
serves as the uh mythical basis for the
Elian mystery
they all also concern to one degree or
another giving the initiate a pleasant
afterlife so when we look at the the the
mystery Cults one of the most recurring
themes across these Mysteries is always
this seeking of of a pleasant afterlife
that we can do things in this life we
can become initiated in this life which
will lead us to a better afterlife for
our
soul um and
again people like Herodotus connects
these groups to the Egyptians and the
Egyptians had very elaborate ideas about
the afterlife so it isn't impossible
that that stuff comes from some sort of
Egyptian Source uh but whatever the case
this is one of those very much recurring
themes in all these mystery calls this
was not something
that many of you know about the the the
the ideas of the afterlife in ancient
the ancient Atlantic world you went to
Hades everyone basically went to the
same place just like in the Hebrew Bible
everyone goes to shol um in ancient
Greece everyone goes to Hades but the
mystery call seems to have another idea
that we can sort of affect our afterlife
that afterlife can be more or less
Pleasant and that things we do in this
life in this case particularly becoming
initiated into these Mysteries that will
affect our
afterlife and if you want
to many people have of course connected
this to later ideas in um in the
abrahamic religions for in in
Christianity about heaven and hell and
sort of judgment after death and while
many might perhaps connect this idea to
Zoras
anism uh which also has a similar idea
about our actions in this life affecting
the way we experienc the afterlife there
might also be a source in these ideas in
these Mysteries like like in quote
unquote orphism right and many people
have speculated that we can find certain
um precursors to things like
Christianity in in these Mysteries that
is speculation but it is interesting to
consider for sure U this might be
another one of the the the sources for
many of those ideas that would become so
prominent in later centuries while these
mystery calls are usually considered
distinct Traditions or groups some have
speculated that they may represent
different aspects of a wider quote
unquote mystery religion in ancient
Greece
we're not going to solve that issue
today but this certainly helps us
understand that such practices and ideas
which many of us would deem to be pretty
mystical were a very prominent feature
of the culture and religion in the
ancient helenic world but we can also
look at some of the more intellectual
features of ancient Greece because these
quote unquote mystical aspects include
some of those famous philosophers
associated with sober
rationalism par menes often consider the
first metaphysician or at least the
first philosopher to deal with ontology
in history wrote the famous
philosophical poem called on nature
where he expounds his shocking idea that
everything is in fact
one everything is simply being being is
one and cannot undergo any change and
how did he reach this monistic
conclusion on the nature of
reality well he was a philos phers so
through philosophizing right well that
depends on how broadly we defined
philosophizing indeed in the opening to
his work he tells us that he was thrust
into an experience where he traveled and
where did he travel to the underworld
thus we see here another illusion to
katabasis he travels through this
underworld in a chariot led by mares
escorted by the quote unquote Daughters
of the Sun as they leave the House of
Night for the light passing through the
yawning Abyss before being greeted by an
unnamed goddess who imparts on him the
secrets of
reality many have interpreted this as
only a sort of poetic metaphorical
ornament at the beginning of the work
but that seems to me at least pretty
naive what certainly seems to be going
on here is that Parmenides is describing
a very real to him mystical experience
through which he received mystical
insight into the truth of reality that
truth to Parmenides was a radical monism
reality is an undifferentiated whole it
is one and without change the mundane
reality of change and multiplicity that
we experience is only our senses and
limited Minds misleading us but through
mystical Insight he has been given the
truth which he expounds in this famous
and influential philosophical work so
here we have one of the most influential
and important philosophers in history
history who influenced some of the great
figures like Plato and Aristotle having
a kind of mysticism at the very core
holding up his philosophy again this is
one interpretation of the account at the
beginning of paredes's treatise U many
will still interpret it in a different
way that no this is just sort of
metaphor just a way of of opening it in
a in a poetic way because it is a poem
after all and that you know the bulk of
the work is philosophy and it is
philosophy when you read the the work
you know he is is arguing for his case
right so he's a philosopher in that
sense but I think we do ourselves a
disservice if we discount this very
dramatic part the beginning of his poem
uh which seems also to connect to ideas
of catabasis of descent into the
underworld there's all this imagery
right that alludes to the mysteries for
instance which we will see also in other
philosophers I think we can't discredit
that as just being some sort of you know
poetic metaphor but that it is alluding
to this truth through this this um
knowledge that he's trying to impart
that this was the result in some way of
a can of what we would refer to as some
kind of mystical experience or at least
some kind of altered state of
consciousness and later figures such as
Plato himself isn't much different of
course platonism is strongly associated
with mysticism and a lot of what we call
mysticism indeed comes from the platonic
framework and vocabulary but a lot of
this comes from these so-called
neoplatonists like like platinus who
lived a few centuries ad it isn't as
clear in Plato himself unless we project
the ideas of platinus onto Plato which
many do of course so reading Plato
through the lens of platinus but in the
dialogues of Plato themselves there are
also indications that there's a kind of
mysticism at play here and that aside
from the importance of reason and
argument for arriving at truth there's
an even higher source of knowledge that
of mania or divine Madness through which
we receive wisdom directly from the
Divine in general of course Plato is
famous for having esoteric or so-called
Unwritten doctrines we find references
to these Unwritten teachings in
Aristotle but they're also important for
the later neoplatonist as a source for
their particular interpretation of the
master that there were teachings or
aspects of pl's thought that he didn't
Express overtly in his dialogues is hard
to deny as we seem to find this state in
his own writings too particularly in his
seventh letter which most Scholars agree
to be authentic by Plato himself where
he Al also of course speaks as himself
rather than through Socrates and the
dialogues he seems to say here that
there are aspects of his teachings that
he won't write down and indeed that
can't be written down or expressed in
words he says quote there is no writing
of mine about these matters nor will
there ever be one for this knowledge is
not something that can be put into words
like other science
but after long continued intercourse
between teacher and pupil in joint
pursuit of the subject suddenly like a
light flashing forth when a fire is
kindled it is born in the soul and
straight way nourishes itself he seems
to allude here to some kind of
Illumination which quote flashes forth
which is pretty mystical
language but the details of what this
entails he doesn't say of course since
the whole point of the quot is to say
that he won't do precisely that but I
think we can possibly see some hints or
pointers toward this idea in the
dialogues themselves here of course it
is usually Socrates that is the main
character through which Plato is
speaking and it can be hard to know if
what is said represents Plato's own
ideas or simply a retelling of his
teacher Socrates although I usually tend
to lean toward the former option for
example in dialogues like the fedo which
depicts socrates's last moments with his
friends and students before drinking the
hemlock and dying we get some
interesting contemp ations on the goals
and nature of the philosophic life as
well as a striking and almost
psychedelic Vision toward the end the
philosophic life and the way to reach
philosophical truths according to
Socrates in this dialogue involves a
turning away from the body and senses to
where the soul is left alone quote and
does purification not turn out to be
what we mentioned in our argument some
time ago namely to separate the soul as
far as possible from the body and
accustom it to gather itself and collect
itself out of every part of the body and
to dwell by itself as far as it can both
now and in the future freed as it were
from the bonds of the body the path that
Socrates and Plato is describing here
seems to be a kind of aesthetic and
spiritual discipline where the soul can
Ascend to higher realities and perhaps
to interpolate into the text a little
bit to unite with Divine realities in
this case the forms and the form of the
forms you may think this is stretching
things a bit and it might be but this
theme of mystical illumination and
Revelation as a highest form of of
wisdom becomes perhaps most clear in the
fages and the Symposium two dialogues
that both discuss the nature of Love or
AOS in the Symposium alabes very
tellingly compares the philosophic
wisdom that Socrates has um initiated
the rest of the company with to the Baka
or Mania the Divine Madness associated
with the ecstatic rights and aled States
Of Consciousness that we mentioned
earlier particularly in relation to the
theak cult of dianis he says quote well
something much more painful than a snake
has bitten me in my most sensitive part
I mean my heart or my soul or whatever
you want to call it which has been
struck and bitten by philosophy whose
grip on young and eager Souls is much
more vicious than a Viper and makes them
do the most amazing things now all you
people here have all shared in the
madness the Bic frenzy of
philosophy and in my opinion it is in
the fedis that this sentiment is most
strongly expressed as the dialogue is a
positive celebration of divine Mania or
Madness the famous story takes place in
the wilderness outside of Athens where
Socrates sits down next to fedis reads
him a speech that lisius has held about
love and
friendship at first Socrates seems to
agree that erotic love is something
dangerous it makes people go mad with
desire hindering their moral faculties
and clear thinking but then through an
intervention of his guiding Dion
Socrates changes his mind and instead
holds a new speech in Praise of mania or
Madness or erotic Madness
particularly he makes a clear
distinction between human Madness
brought on by things like diseases on
the one hand and on the other hand a
Divine Madness or Mania that is given by
the gods and this kind of Madness is the
highest and most beautiful of states
that the soul can experience at least in
this life he furthermore divides Divine
Mania into four categories prophetic
Mania such as the Oracle Deli being
inspired by the god to speak bakic
Madness associated with the rituals and
initiations of the cult of dianis poetic
Mania that is when the muses influence a
poets or maybe musicians for instance to
create F art and lastly erotic Mania or
The Madness of Love which he sees as the
most exalted of them all in an
absolutely beautiful section Socrates or
Plato explains that the soul can become
enraptured by Beauty in the world that
one becomes mad with Divine Madness and
illumination he explains that before we
as Souls came into our bodies we knew
the true realities in Plato thought the
forms intimately and directly but most
of us have forgotten now being caught up
with the world of matter and
Change but there Still Remains a
remembrance of that original knowledge
within us and when a person that has
trained himself probably through
aestheticism and contemplations that was
talked about in the Ido he can look at
Beauty in the physical world such as a
beautiful young boy in this case or
perhaps a sunset or a tree and through
seeing that beauty is reminded of the
true real beauty of the
Divine when this happens Socrates says
the wings of the Soul begin to grow back
and we become mad with that
contemplation we receive Divine Mania
which orients our soul to leave this
world and experience or contemplate the
true realities on high he says quote for
just this reason it is fair that only a
philosopher's mind grows Wings since its
memory always keeps it as close as
possible to those realities by being
close to which the gods are divine
a man who uses reminders of these things
correctly is always at the highest most
perfect level of initiation and he is
the only one who is perfect as perfect
can be he stands outside human concerns
and draws close to the Divine ordinary
people think he is Disturbed and rebuke
him for this unaware that he's possessed
by a god notice here that he uses the
language of initiation once again
pointing to the mystical rituals of the
mystery cults
when the philosophers enters this state
other people see him as mad but this
madness is a Divine Madness a divinely
inspired alteration of Consciousness
where true wisdom is achieved he later
says quotes but Beauty was radiant to
see at that time when the souls along
with the Glorious chorus saw the blessed
and spectacular vision and were ushered
into the mystery that we may rightly
call The Most Blessed of all and we who
celebrated it were holy perfect and free
free from All the Troubles that awaited
Us in time to come and we gazed and
raptured that secret revealed objects
that were perfect and simple and
unshakable and
Blissful that was the ultimate vision
and we saw it in pure light because we
were pure ourselves not buried in this
thing we are carrying around now which
we call a body locked in it like an
oyster in its
shell clearly this is not your regular
logical deduction or rational
epistemology that we associate with the
philosophers
rather it seems here that Plato or
Socrates is talking about some kind of
mystical experience or altered state of
consciousness Madness or Mania not
reason deduction using logic the
ultimate knowledge is a pure knowledge
of recollection where we through
contemplative practice and thus then
being possessed by the Divine Madness
escape from the body and our soul can
recollect the true realities that it
knew before Incarnation and even become
maybe once again United to those pure
Divine realities thus receiving
knowledge directly through a kind of
Revelation or illumination this is
perhaps what Plato referred to earlier
as that which is quote like a light
flashing forth when a fire is kindled
being born in the soul erer dods wrote
in his classic work that AOS had a
special importance in Plato's thought as
being the one mode of experience which
brings together the two Natures of man
the Divine self and the tethered Beast
for Eros is frankly rooted in what
shares with the animals the
physiological impulse of sex yet AOS
also supplies the dynamic impulse which
drives the soul forward in its quest for
a satisfaction transcending Earthly
experience with that said this doesn't
mean that reason doesn't have a place of
course it does as Plato is very clear
about but I think we can see here that
he recognizes multiple sources of wisdom
or knowledge that can be balanced Julia
ustinova writes this Revelation
interpreted as a recollection ction of
the ideal forms seen by the philosopher
soul in the past life is to be checked
by reason and reason alone cannot lead
to the transcendental
reality therefore both the philosophers
Mania and reason are necessary
preconditions for his perception of
Truth on top of this there are stories
of Socrates behaving in Peculiar ways in
several accounts Socrates seems to
become completely Frozen in place for
long periods of time on one occasion for
a whole day and night occupied with some
quote unquote
problem well this is of course a certain
level of speculation this certainly
sounds like a kind of altered state of
consciousness a mystical experience that
he would become en raptured in from time
to time a good example to show that this
Mania or Baka didn't have to be the
frenzied crazy behavior that was most
associated with the term but could also
be a kind of inner contemplation or
Rapture finally in the famous dialogue
The Republic Plato seems to argue that
knowledge of the true reality or
realities comes from a kinship with them
on part of the soul and through becoming
United with that Divine reality so to
say quote then won't it be reasonable
for us to plead in his defense that is
the nature of the real lover of learning
to struggle toward what is not to remain
with any of the many things that are
believed to be that as he moves on he
neither loses nor left his erotic love
until he grasps the being of each nature
itself with the part of his soul that is
fitted to grasp it because of its
kinship with it and that once getting
near what really is and having
intercourse with it and having begotten
understanding and Truth he knows truly
lives is nourished and at that point but
not before is relieved from the Pains of
giving
birth if we read this through the lens
of someone like platinus and the
neoplatonist we can of course interpret
many of these words and phrases as
referring to a kind of mystical
experience in ontology that I've alluded
to before the soul has a kinship with
these realities could be read as
referring to the idea that the Soul's
home is in the Divine world of the news
it is the news and her having
intercourse with it also certainly
smells of a kind of unom mystica the
Soul becoming United with the higher
realities again this is reading it
through a neoplatonic lens and it isn't
at all clear if this is what Plato
himself self means but statements like
the ones we have quoted seems to suggest
to many at least that Plato was familiar
with some kind of un mystica or mystical
Union which could be what he refers to
in the letter as those things which
cannot be put into words but which he
found the closest our best way of
expressing through the language of
erotic love and Madness this is of
course very interesting as it reminds us
of many other mystical Traditions that
similarly used erotic language of love
longing and sometimes even sex to
express the ineffable experience of
longing for and uniting with the Divine
from the suies to Christian Mystics and
shites in India but like I said not
everyone agrees that we can find these
mystical themes in Plato and Socrates
and this discussion has involved certain
levels of you could say educated
speculation on my part and on part of
the scholars that I've used as Source
but I think it's at least definitely
worth considering seriously since so
many parts of the dialogue seems to
point to this idea that the highest
wisdom is somehow uh achieved through
Divine Madness what's known as Mania as
a kind of Revelation that is then
checked by reason and so these two
aspects of epistemology work together in
the true in the true philosopher both
Divine Mania and reason and logical
deduction from these examples I hope I
have shown that the um IM image of the
ancient helenic world as a purely
rational culture devoid of any quote
unquote mystical content is simply false
in fact once we start to look a little
deeper we find a whole plethora of such
practices and ideas from the practices
of the religious cults that were so
popular to the mainstream population all
the way to the writings and ideas of
those famous philosophers that we all
know and love who are usually portrayed
as paradigms of rationalism and science
but as we've SE
there is a whole other side to their
lives and works that make many modern
enthusiasts uncomfortable but which is
impossible to ignore once you start
seeing it of course as always this has
just been a very general overview of a
few examples of what we could call you
know mysticism or mystical experience in
ancient Greece um you know that word
mysticism we all know it's it's it's a
word that has issues um and using it in
this context like this sort of you know
the academic inside me is sort of
screaming at me but I think if we base
it on this working definition that we've
had that we established at the beginning
of the episode I and we're all also
aware of the problems with the term that
we've discussed both here and in
previous episodes I think we can sort of
get away with it uh and so with that in
mind this has been just a few examples
of what we might be able to call
mysticism in ancient Greece or at least
examples of some kind of um altered
state of consciousness uh as a means to
wisdom in the ancient helenic world
there is of course a lot more that we
could discuss so please uh let me know
in the comments if you there's any
particular topic within this wider
subject that you would like me to cover
in the future uh like I said there's
plenty of stuff to to get into there so
so yeah uh feel free to leave me uh
suggestions uh as always I would like to
thank all my patrons who keep this
channel going um this really is the best
way to support this channel as you
probably know the YouTube algorithm can
be very unpredictable and so to have
people support me monetarily like that
is uh truly so appreciated and I I'm
very thankful for that um I would highly
of course appreciate if anyone else
wanted to become a patron too so we'll
leave links to that in the description
and in the pin comment you can also
support the channel by a one-time
donation through PayPal there are links
to that there too um what else uh if you
want to find me on my socials I I'll
leave some links here I have I'm on
Instagram I'm on Tik Tok I'm all over
the place so uh go follow me there if
you're interested in some of my work
including some of my music as well as as
the work I do here on let's talk
religion and speaking of music I also
have another channel that is dedicated
to primarily to music so many of you
will know that uh I make the majority of
the music for the videos on this channel
myself and so on my other channel which
is called Philip Palm I post music my
own music as well as music content
generally so if you're interested in
that go check that out for now I hope
this has been an educational and
interesting video on quote unquote
mysticism in ancient Greece uh look
forward to more videos on similar topics
in the future and I will see you next
[Music]
time